你跟他在一起有什么好身体，
身体搞不好，
主动主动剔除了赚钱的生意，
赚钱的生意被他接盘了，
你跟他在一起你得到什么了？
把财产的事情白纸黑字的写清楚，
约定明白，
他欠你多少钱，
什么时候还，
如果不还的话怎么办，
承担什么违约金啊？
我今年41，
男朋友呢37，
一起十年了，
在这十年里面我自然流产了三次6，
后面做了一次试管也没有成功，
检查了才知道她精子有问题，
但是现在所有的人，
包括她家人都觉得是我的问题，
都已经检查结果出来了，
她都不承认自己有问题吗？
她也没跟她家里人说是她的问题，
这么没有担当吗？
我那个时候流产了之后呢，
有一点那个腺肌症，
就是子宫内膜移位症，
这个也是有一点影响的，
但是在这个之前，
前面流产的原因一直都没有找到，
现在关键是呃，
流产三次之后，
然后加上大量的激素，
我导致了那个内膜异位症很严重，
卵巢囊肿也很大，
癌标都高了，
现在医生都已经建议那个把子宫切除，
我其实家庭条件还可以，
大学毕业之后呢，
我创业生意很好，
买了车又买了房，
嗯，
他呢，
就是外地农农村的兄弟两个，
他爸爸外面还欠了钱让他来还，
他那时候没还就导致他进了那个失信名单，
那也是我后来才知道的，
这个失信名单我才知。
呃了，
刚谈恋爱的时候，
我们也不知道，
后面他做生意借了几十个嘛，
又亏了，
我是看他挺可怜的，
因为我自己做生意做的挺好，
就开始带他做生意，
为了照顾他面子嘛，
客户沟通啊，
签约都是我来的，
合同他来写，
钱呢就转给他，
然后当时呢，
说好的大家都是一人一半的，
刚开始的时候就是是按照规定就是分的，
但是后来没有完全实行，
但是呢，
给我开通了那个亲情付，
也只不过是呢，
用于日常的一些外卖啊，
淘宝这些的，
他那个时候对我控制也蛮强的，
还老师不放心我，
十年前嘛，
条件各方面都还好，
而且我个子也还有一米六八，
长相各方面都还可以，
查我，
还跟踪我，
但是呢，
他那个时候对我就是情绪价值这块照顾的很好，
对我各方面照顾的也还可以，
那时候经常也救助些小动物啊什么的，
他也很支持我，
那个候觉得他人也蛮善良的，
所以大家就在一起，
就这么谈嘛，
就第二次怀孕嘛，
到将近5个月的时候，
她偷偷去见前女友，
然后我就问他，
他就气的就不行了，
因为那时候我做三份生意忙得不得了，
激动的太自己见红了嘛，
他说是因为前女友欠他钱，
后面呢，
打官司把钱是要了回来，
说是那个女的因为诈骗进去了，
后面孩子没了，
是个男孩儿，
门诊上没有麻药，
直接清宫，
打那后医生急诊的医生她不专业，
是半夜去的嘛，
后期要进行那个宫腔镜，
不知道是因为麻药原因还是因为什么原因，
头昏昏了9。
个月，
就是人不能爬起来，
只能就是半躺着，
我所有的声音全部停了，
然后后来做试管也没有用麻药，
30多厘米，
就是把膀胱都扎破了，
我心里创伤，
加上他内水对我也很冷漠，
我就抑郁嘛，
不想活，
医生说分散点注意力嘛，
然后我就说那我就回公司把前面的时候这个自媒体嘛，
就是把生意做到自媒体嘛，
生意开始爆了，
因为公司太忙了，
因为所有的决策啊什么的，
我也在参与嘛，
我知道很忙，
我就跟他说，
我说回去了，
他也不同意，
说怕我辛苦，
最近呢，
我跟他说，
我说我去转账，
他说是说同意了，
但是呢，
我还没回，
我想问问你这个情况我该怎么办，
就在去年的时候吧，
他回老家半夜偷偷出去瞎玩，
正好被我发现了，
打电话给他爸妈嘛，
他爸妈的意思就是说，
因为我没跟他回老家，
所以他才出去玩，
反正挺护着他，
过年回来了，
她天天挂这个脸，
然后我妈当时呢，
也查出那个肺结节，
医生怀疑是那个原位癌，
要介议手术，
我就心疼我妈天天看她脸色嘛，
就主动找他谈，
她还咬我一口，
还造黄苗，
说你分手可以，
但是不要在我头上扣10盆子，
她同意了，
我让她说，
我说你写个分手协议吧，
以后到家进了不要纠缠，
我真的很累了，
他也不同意，
他开始算账，
甚至算到就是他那时候黑户的的，
好几年前黑户的时候转给我的钱，
包括那时候我做月子，
他照顾我的时候，
我的现金货款都是让他去。
疼了，
让他再转给我的，
那时候钱也蛮多的，
他讲了这些让我算账的这些话嘛，
我就很寒心嘛，
我就跟他讲，
我说当时做生意说好的一人一半，
我应得的不跟你谈了，
你就把我孩子的命和我剩的半条命算一下，
后来我说你现在收入大概也百来万，
就协商，
后来就转2万块钱每个月吧，
他后来转是转了，
但是是微信转账，
备注的是分红，
上个月呢，
我让他补贴了一个分润协议，
他在公账上面给我打工资，
但是吵完架几个月之后，
很奇怪，
他又弄了个求婚，
弄得很隆重的，
今年5月份我们办了那个婚礼，
没有戒指，
没有五金，
说了是以后补，
他爸妈没有出一分，
还报拿了钱嘛，
然后当时酒席钱也不够，
还问我借了4万，
说是拿了4万，
说是借了吧，
我们俩就是一个相反，
他就比较活泼那种的，
她从来也不跟我交流，
吵架那也吵不到一块儿，
现在呢情绪也很不稳定，
我不知道讲到什么话，
他突然就爆了，
我现在呢，
每个月大姨妈疼的就跟死过一会一样啊，
中度贫血，
医生呢要让我早睡早起啊，
还要心情好一点，
但是呢，
她每天就要直播啊什么嘛，
反正每天睡觉都很晚，
现在呢，
说我什么没人要啦，
他吃瞎子呢，
因为他现在在我们当地是个网红嘛，
现在嫌我这样嫌我那样吧，
说我强势了，
现在看一些视频啊，
都是什么本店的小搭子，
他现在债卖也还了，
车房也满。
啊，
然后去年的时候还满世界说要给我换车，
外面的人都以为是给我买的，
他投了一套房子，
从我这儿拿了200个，
他当时不能出面，
就由我代持的，
问题是钱没有经他的手，
就是直接转给房东了。
上个月他让我过户给他到账了133个，
又让我直接转了20个给借给他首付的人，
我让他写了一张87万的借条，
就重新写一下嘛。
他当时就发火了，
他问我你是不是咨询律师了，
如果我不相信，
他可以去领个证。
我说你写借条不是应该的吗？
律息都没有算，
他就跟我讲，
他说以前转你的钱就当利息了，
这张借条写的是写了，
但是我心里总共还是就他这样讲的话，
我真的很不踏实，
就是说房子卖掉了，
钱你回笼了一部分资金，
然后剩下的差价他欠你87万，
是这个意思吧，
是的，
好，
那你现在想问我什么问题呢？
就是这个房子因为是个大头嘛，
就像他说的，
以前也有转账给我，
微信上面也有，
因为最开始我们不是做生意的嘛，
也会有资金来往，
包括他打给我，
那个时候我们在一起做生意的时候，
那时候我也是一参与的，
所以他会打给我包，
后来因为各式各样的情况没有打，
但是也会有转账嘛，
那他现在这个钱是因为转过户给他，
然后又是我这边转出去的20个会怎么样，
他现在说他要去贷款，
因为我们俩前两个吵了一。
他就跟我讲，
他说他去贷款给我，
我觉得是这样啊，
你们两个人呢，
因为办了婚礼，
有求婚，
有婚礼，
但是没有结婚证，
但你自己感觉你跟他还能过得下去吗？
你要是觉得你跟他过不下去的话，
现在你们两个人之间就应该签一个协议，
白纸黑字的写清楚当年我们是一个什么合伙关系，
分红是应该是怎么分的，
分到多少钱，
现在因为你已经不参与经营了，
可能我们要结束这样的合伙关系，
写明白之间的这个经济账，
他欠你多少钱，
多长时间之内给你，
以前是你带着他挣钱，
现在是他自己挣钱，
挣得风生水起，
就是他夺了你的命，
你跟他在一起干嘛呢？
以后你想当妈妈的话，
咱们也可以收养他，
现在的意思就是说他有个同学在做这个就是乖的生意嘛，
他想就是借，
因为我现在的话也不可能啊，
你想要孩子，
你也不能跟这个人在一起，
因为这个人真的是夺了你的运，
夺了你的命，
他并不爱你，
你也知道他当众求婚是一种什么行为，
这种表演性人格，
他之所以现在选择你，
可能还是因为你也有一定的存款，
有一定的经济价值嘛，
你自己好好想清楚，
这些年当你流产的时候，
她是什么表现，
当你躺半年的时候，
你自己好好想清楚，
这个人值不值得再继续纠缠下去，
其实我流产的时候，
他那时候照顾我，
对我照顾的很好，
你为什。
他流得产，
你忘了我，
因为他找他前面那个女的，
你才流得产，
你跟他在一起有什么好身体，
身体搞不好主动主动切除了赚钱的生意，
赚钱的生意被他接盘了，
你跟他在一起你得到什么了？
把财产的事情白纸黑字的写清楚，
约定明白，
他欠你多少钱，
什么时候还，
如果不还的话怎么办，
承担什么违约金，
他现在我估计在让他写，
他估计不太违愿意，
他现在不是他很在乎自己的人设吗？
他很在乎自己的名誉吗？
他很在乎自己在外面的表现吗？
他在乎这个他就得签，
那这个我是需要去找律师，
找律师对白纸可以自写清楚啊，
彼此之间没有什么，
没有起什么其他的这个经济纠纷了，
没有什么共同的债务了，
他该欠你多少钱，
什么时候该支付给你，
那我当时跟他写的那个利润分成合同协议的话，
这个管用吗？
我觉得这个事情咱们要客观一点，
你参与经营，
你分利润应该应份的，
你不参与经营，
你还想着一辈子分摊的利润，
那是不可能的。
嗯，
那我这张借条的话，
写的算有法律依据吗？
有啊，
白纸黑字写明白是什么原因啊，
当初我200万借给你买房子，
买房子当时是登记在我的名下，
后来这个房子过户给你了，
这个房子回收的资金是多少钱？
所以你还欠我多少钱？
我觉得白纸黑字写明白，
这很正常啊，
对对，
真实写啊，
那就行啊，
那没问题啊，
你不要怪我这个。
我话说的太难听了，
我听到的时候我眼圈都红了，
你怎么还不清醒，
怎我就不能够清醒的认识到他是来克你的，
他夺了你的命，
夺了你的运，
你跟他纠缠干什么？
你其实吧，
那个时候我是想分开的，
但是呢，
因为我母亲她也不能说怪我母亲，
不是说这个意思，
我妈妈这一路走来很辛苦，
我爸因为给人做担保嘛，
哎，
我们家人都太善良了，
可能就是没脑子了，
因为这个事情我妈就说的家里要有个男的，
就是也很愚昧嘛，
就一直劝我自己再好好想一想啊，
想让孩子咱们积极起来也可以领养，
是不是单身女性可以领养的，
不是非得有结婚证的，
就是你领养的，
如果说是同性的女孩子的话，
她没有年龄的这样一个差的要求，
如果你领养的是男孩子的话，
有一个40岁年龄差的要求，
单身女性也是可以领养的，
嗯嗯，
好拜拜啊拜拜，
嗯，
好多人说为什么要相差40岁，
就性别上既然单身的女性可以领养，
那么单身的男性也可以领养，
所以如果你领养的孩子跟你性别是不一样的，
那么他有一个道德元素在里面啊，
有一个防风险的元素在里面，
他就要求相差年龄40岁，
如果说你领养的性别跟你是一样的，
他就没有这个要求，
说你非得差40岁，
明白这个意思了啊，
记忆。
点赞关注哦。